Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy,
a Grammy and Tony-winning
actress,
you know from shows such
as "Sex and the City,"
"Ratched," and the new
HBO series, "The Gilded Age."
She executive produces
and stars in
"And Just Like That,"
with new episodes premiering
Thursdays on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-I have a favor to ask,
and it involves manual labor
and you two coming to Brooklyn.
-Well, how can we say no?
-Aww.
-Oh, no, no. I'm asking,
how can we say no?
-You can't.
We need a huge turnout
on Saturday to finish painting
the women's shelter
I've been working on with Nya,
and it would be so great
if you guys would come help.
-I'm there,
and I'll bring the kids.
I'm a really good painter.
-Carrie?
-Oh, well,
when I was on stage crew
in high school,
they asked me,
"Please stop painting,"
so I will happily write a check.
-You can't be the white lady
who just writes a check.
If I can paint, you can paint.
-Please welcome back
to the show,
Cynthia Nixon, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I am so happy to
have you back here!
-I am so happy to be here!
-In a studio full of people,
no less.
-So lovely.
-It's not bad, right?
-And a band, even.
-And a band.
We did see each
other right before --
we were talking backstage --
right before the pandemic.
Late February of 2020.
-Yes.
-We were at the
Pen Awards in New York City,
and it was a lovely evening
and a few people
were starting to do fist pumps,
and I was like,
"Come on, guys."
And yet here we are,
a few years later.
-Yeah, some people
are ahead of the curve.
Not me, but yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, Christine Baranski and I
were there together,
presenting an award
to Tom Stoppard.
-And you and Christine Baranski
are now playing sisters
in "The Gilded Age,"
which is on HBO,
which is very exciting.
But when you were first
on Broadway together,
she was your mother.
-Yes, in 1983,
which I can't believe
is almost 40 years ago,
she was playing my mother,
and I didn't realize
she was really too young
to be my mother.
But now we're sisters.
That's good. That's good.
-You know,
right after, I feel like,
maybe the last time we talked,
I saw another
very young Cynthia Nixon.
I had never seen
the movie "Amadeus."
-Oh, yeah.
-And you're in "Amadeus."
-Yes.
-You just show up as a maid.
-Yes. Yes.
-That must have been
one of your first film roles.
-Oh, I had been acting about
five years at that point.
-Well, I'm sorry that I've
missed the earlier work.
-"Little Darlings"? You haven't
seen "Little Darlings?"
-I'll put it on the list.
-Well, but it was such
a big deal for me,
because me and my friends,
Milos Forman,
who directed that,
was our absolute
favorite director
from "Ragtime" and from "Hair."
And I was in 11th grade,
and I had already been
around the block a little bit.
I kind of knew it was
five months in Czechoslovakia.
I had never been to Europe,
but I said after like, 6,000
auditions and they cast me,
I said,
"I really want to do this part,
but I'm in high school,
and could you, respectfully,
if you don't use me
for two days in a row,
could you fly me back
to New York?"
And they did.
-So you went back and forth
the whole time?
-Yes. Yes.
Because I knew, even --
I'd been around a little bit,
since I was 11, 12,
and I knew they were just
going to put me in a hotel
for months on end,
and it was going to be
challenging in 11th grade.
-Yeah.
-So they tested me.
First, they flew me out
for a 45 minute rehearsal.
-Really?
-To see if I balked.
And I just, you know,
just smiled and smiled,
and they flew me back and forth
like, five or six times.
-You must have gotten
so many miles.
-I did.
-Also, I'm glad you said this.
Please don't take this
the wrong way.
When you said you were going
to be there for five months,
you're not in
a lot of the movie.
-No, that's what I mean. Right.
-Yeah.
-But I know, I was very,
very low on the pecking order,
and they're just going to
throw me in a hotel room
and forget about me
and a few months later, be like,
"Let's get that girl out here
for that one thing.
She's got that one line."
-Now the other thing about the
last time you were on this show,
you were running for governor of
this state and you didn't win,
but the guy who did win,
things didn't go great for.
-And just like that,
Andrew Cuomo was out of a job.
-And just like that.
What a lovely tie-in.
-You know, the difference
between him and me is,
neither of us are governor.
-Yeah.
-But I've still got
to keep my Emmys.
-That's true. He didn't even
get to keep his one Emmy.
So congratulations
on that as well.
So "And Just Like That,"
I imagine all of you
must have been somewhat hesitant
to return
to this beloved franchise.
I think we were hesitant
and also very excited.
Kind of equal measure because,
of course, we love the show.
We love each other. We love
our characters, all that.
But again, to revisit this show
that everybody loves
so much, so iconic --
and also,
I guess my main concern
that I kept stating
over and over again was,
if we go back,
it can't be a reboot.
It can't just be this same show
almost 25 years later.
We're very different people.
The world is different.
It was always
an unbelievably white show,
which was not so cool back then,
and it's really, we obviously,
definitely have to change that.
So it was also a chance
to hopefully, you know,
we got a lot right
in that first show,
but we got some things wrong
and we got a chance
to go back and change them.
-You did something that
I feel like a lot of people
have done in recent years,
which is, you went back
and binged the show itself.
-Yes. Yes.
-So were you watching it
as it went through?
Would you watch each week
when you were making the show?
-Oh, definitely.
-But had you never watched it
all at once like that?
-No. No.
-Yeah?
-I mean, it was delightful.
-I mean, I did it.
We've talked about it,
but I did it with my wife.
I'd never seen it.
We binged it together,
and I fell in love
with you ladies.
I'm going to just be honest.
-Aww.
[ Applause ]
-Well, I think that, you know,
we were one of those things
that people turned to
during the quarantine
and really binged, you know?
-Yeah.
-Well, I think that any...
It was funny
the shows people found,
because it was obviously
a deeply lonely time.
And this was, you know,
this show has always been
about friendship and connection,
and so it makes total sense
to me that it would be
a show that people
would sort of find comfort in
during those difficult times.
-Yeah. Yeah.
And, you know, as we were
all locked in our houses too,
it's like, you know,
a bunch of people
strutting around the city,
going to fabulous restaurants
and wearing beautiful clothes
and doing all the things.
-And it is such a snapshot
of that era of New York.
It is.
-Wild. Wild. Yes.
Matthew Broderick
always says this thing
when he's walking down
the street with Sarah Jessica
and he sees a girl
in a particular
kind of an outfit and heels,
and he always says,
"You did that.
That's your fault."
-That is very true. To this day,
that is very true.
One thing
that you've also changed
about this second iteration
of the show --
the subway.
We did not see much
of the subway
in the first "Sex and the City."
Maybe never even once.
-Yeah, I think there was,
Carrie for about 30 seconds,
briefly flirted
with taking a bus,
and then someone said to her,
"You're on the bus.
Why do you have to take the bus
if your photo is on the bus?"
And she was like, "Yeah."
Yeah, I mean, I certainly,
in non-COVID times,
I'm on the subway every day.
In COVID times I'm on
the subway maybe once a week.
-Yeah.
-And yeah, I mean,
I always felt like Miranda --
you know,
Miranda works in Manhattan.
She lives in Brooklyn.
-She was probably on the subway.
-I think she was on the subway,
but we never showed it.
-We just never showed it.
-Yeah.
-It's a different era now.
People people deeply
want to see the subway.
-They want to see the subway.
-Because, let me say something
about New York City,
if you've never been here,
the subway is better
than it's ever been.
[ Laughter ]
And now you have two shows
on at the same time,
and they both take place
in New York
with a 140-year time gap.
-Yes.
-So "The Gilded Age" is
late 1800s New York City.
Do you enjoy the costume-drama-y
type of show?
-I do.
I mean, it's, you know,
the corsets are not really
your friend.
They're your adversary.
-Sure.
-But certainly, the clothes are
amazingly beautiful and the wigs
and all of the sets.
And then we shot in a lot of
real historic mansions
in Troy, New York
and in Newport, Rhode Island.
And I mean,
it's gorgeous to look at,
and it's a period
not unlike our own
where you have these --
then, they were millionaires
who appeared out of nowhere
because of
the Industrial Revolution
and the railroads
and business was booming.
And, you know, they built
these palatial mansions.
Now we have these billionaires
who appear out of nowhere
because of the tech boom
and they're, you know,
visiting outer space and stuff.
So it's similar, kind of like,
people with so much money
they really just don't know
what to do with it.
-They don't know
At least 140 years ago,
they built houses
that are still here.
I don't know what this
space thing is gonna give us.
I have one thing I got to say.
We've talked about
Steve in the past.
-Yeah.
-Steve's not having
a great time in the new show.
-He is not.
-Yeah.
You know I love Steve.
-I love Steve, too.
-Feel like I don't know why you
guys did him like that.
-Awww.
-And part of it is, you know,
that I have a very good
Steve impression.
-Would you like to
share it with me?
-I would like to.
-Would you like to share it
with all of us?
-Well, I'd just like
to share it with you,
but if they want to watch...
-Okay.
[ Applause ]
-[ As Steve ] Oh, Miranda.
-Oh, that's very good.
It's very good.
-You're a very good actor.
-If I was blindfolded,
I would never know
it was not David.
-You guys,
that is Cynthia Nixon.
"And Just Like That"
and "The Gilded Age"
are both available now
on HBO and HBO Max.